all right you know him for his pillows
but my Glendale wants to have you know
at least in the near future or for his
face vast because he is trying to make
sure that he can make as many as
possible to help what is something that
is in serious short supply
Michael in Delhi my fellow CEO with us
right now Mike good a view me on y'all
so tell me what got you doing this and
why you're doing this and how it's
coming along doing this well it was
about three weeks ago and I and I heard
the president whether to get everybody
involved in what everything they could
for helping out that medical the
hospitals and everything and I and I
started doing my due diligence and
figuring out what we could make and and
how fast they can ramp up and within at
the beginning of this week I finally got
down the prototype I wanted and we
converted in three days a 200,000 square
foot factory i've got about 300 or 400
of my workers converted over and we're
making we're up to 10,000 masks a day
and i want to get up to 50,000 by next
week holy cow now who is getting these
mouths you ship them out tonight or yeah
i'm going i'm going right to the
hospitals and the first you know first
responders things like that the mostly
right to the hospital the event since uh
since its kind of been announced i've
been you know taking it all and i've one
person just taking in the request and
we're trying to film as fast as we can
last night i personally worked over
there till about midnight we've we
working around the clock and it's uh
it's just we you know we're all in this
together and we want to get through it
and i'm i'm even looking at the future
being one of the manufacturers that the
president wants to stay in the u.s. we
never go through this problem again with
relying on 95 percent of our medical
supplies from china so how much of the
production overall would do the pillows
and the bed sheets and some of the
others is compromised because you're
doing this very good very promising deed
here what gets the what well well I'm
always very well prepared in my pillow
we're very good at scaling and
so I had I got two identical factories
and the one I completely switched on I'm
about 90% of my my sewing department for
sure and even hiring other swords as
fast as I can and so I would say about
90% of the the what I would be using to
produce pillows but I like I say I had a
I have a big stock I'm always prepared
for emergencies or things that you know
big spikes in sales or what-have-you and
so this has been a it's been a blessing
to my workers to to be able to help out
and and keep everybody going we've had
to redo the factories so that's safe
there everybody's six feet apart and um
different things we've put in place so
so they you know they feel safe coming
to work - you're good man Mike thank you
very very much Mike Lyndell doing his
bit to help the country even if it means
some of his business gets sidelined so
he can do just that thank you Michael